往往那种偏执的病态才是一个人的真相，
平时多么礼貌，
对外人多么客气，
这往往是伪装。
而他对某一件事情就是放不下，
就是钻牛角尖，
就是想要追求这件事情怎么怎么样，
就是想要问你跟前男友之间对了吗？
怎么的感觉好吗，
爽吗？
他就是病态。
目前呢，
我所遇到的问题和其他直播间姐妹比的话肯定很小，
只是我自己呢，
无法自洽，
也不知道怎么办。
我原生家庭很差，
无论是各个方面我都用了很久去质疑自己，
一直在做课题，
分离在婚前呢，
目前呢，
自己也去看了几本婚姻的书，
但是也没有找到答案，
所以来到这里了。
嗯，
好，
你遇到啥问题了？
我和我对象恋爱了4年，
并且已经磨合好，
进入到下一个阶段，
我很确认我们彼此很相爱，
并且决定要进入，
我非常的珍惜，
当时有一个坎儿呢，
我自己很难过去，
也隐瞒了我对象，
我对象对于我的过去非常非常在意，
举个例子吧，
因为我前男友和我的过去，
他可以事无巨细，
你能想到的所有的细节，
无论何时何地，
随时随地，
每一个通宵，
经历了很久反复的确认，
理清了所有的细节，
精神上很折磨我，
因为呢，
一开始认识的时候，
我们不熟的时候，
我曾有一个善意的谎言，
他从那时候对我的不。
但这些呢，
我目前都已经大大方方，
坦坦荡荡，
没有任何沟通的问题的，
只是呢，
知道了他是这种人，
所以今天呢，
这件事我一直不敢开口，
没有开始恋爱前呢，
我曾经有一个恋爱的男生，
这个男生隐瞒了我，
他有女朋友，
导致了我被小，
在一个月左右的时候我发现了，
并且立马的分开，
但这段感情呢，
我付出也蛮多的，
我们也相互转勾账，
在遇到这个对象前呢，
因为这件事情我很害怕，
所以我换了微信手机号，
所有的圈子，
在我和我这个对象恋爱一年的时候，
当时那个人呢，
他又找到了我，
想约我见一面，
问我过得好不好，
我当时的时候得了良性肿瘤，
我告诉他我已经花光身上所有的积蓄，
我过得并不好，
而且有一部私心呢，
我是想告诉他当时对我欺骗，
他得知了，
立马给我讲了，
其实也就2万块钱，
已经过去了三年多了，
这件事，
我也回了他电话，
并且我给他说我现在有对象的一切，
我要把这2万块钱，
当时打电话的时候我说我还回去，
他说他不在意这点钱，
但是呢，
他有一句话现在为什么要提到，
后来他说了，
无论我把他删除拉黑还是怎么样，
他非常的在乎我，
他如果想找我，
肯定可以找得到，
甚至可以找到我老家，
当时其实我并不是很在意，
而且我已经忘了这件事，
已经很。
久了，
前几天的时候，
我对象又提起来了我前男友，
并且因为前男友又回到了那个歇斯底里的状态，
所以我忘记了这件事情，
我又害怕了，
从那个电话之后，
他确实没有找到我，
所以我害怕了几个点，
就是第一个点呢，
我内心不想给我现在的对象提这件事，
但是我愿意听您的意见，
姑娘啊，
你这个事情啊，
你要非常非常认真的听啊，
第一，
前男友那2万块钱退给他，
不要因为这2万块钱让这个前男友有任何再来找你的借口和理由，
对我如果说可以推给他的话，
我想立马都退给他，
用他的电话号码搜他的支付宝就能退给他，
我现在没有他任何的电话号码，
也没有任何联系方式，
因为当时的时候我们才认识一个月都不到，
那你不是说他又来找你了吗？
他是在我恋爱和现在的对象当时快一年的时候过来找我的，
那你不是说现在他又歇斯底里状态了吗？
而是我现在的对象提到我一直隐瞒着这件事情，
提到我就是之前的男朋友的时候，
就是给我理细节什么东西的，
他就很难受，
但是不是任何欺骗的问题，
难受就是他觉得我谈过谈对象，
我第二个要想的讲就是你现在的对象，
你现在这个对象你也要谨慎对待，
不要轻易进入婚姻，
因为以你现在这个对象的做法的话，
他多多少少是有一点偏执人格，
正常情况下的谈恋爱。
不会说事无巨细的去问你跟前男友之间的所有的细节的，
不会的，
如果事无巨细的去问你跟前男友之间的所有的细节的话，
他是一种病态，
所以你对现在这个男朋友也要保持警惕，
而不是说啊，
因为我们很相爱，
怎么怎么样，
就忽略了这些病态。
很多时候摧毁一段关系的不是说别的东西，
就是一种偏执的病态。
平时的时候她对我都很好，
这是假象，
往往那种偏执的病态才是一个人的真相，
平时多么礼貌，
对外人多么客气，
这往往是伪装。
而他对某一件事情就是放不下，
就是钻牛角尖，
就是想要追求这件事情怎么怎么样，
就是想要问你跟前男友之间的吗，
怎么的，
感觉好吗，
爽吗？
他就是病态，
理解了吗？
我理解了，
我们两个已经恋爱4年了，
并且要订婚了，
以天这是我给你的忠告，
你自己认真的谨慎的去考虑一下，
你能不能一辈子面对这样一个病态的人，
安家和对他老婆，
刚开始也是可以给他老婆按脚，
可以给他老婆就什么事无巨细都照顾的非常好，
但这些都是他学来的，
习得的，
不是他的本质，
他的本质就是操控欲极强，
控制欲极强，
自卑，
敏感、
多疑，
这才是本质，
你一定要认真的考虑一下。
你可不可以跟这样一个这么偏执的，
这么敏感的，
这样的一个控制欲强的人生活一辈子，
我的建议是，
因为这些对你好的东西他是很容易改变的，
但一个人的本性是否偏执，
是否有那些执念，
是否有那些超强的控制欲，
这个他是很难改变的，
如果没有专业的心理医生去引导他的话，
这是他的底色。
嗯，
如果你的前男友来找你的话，
第一时间还钱啊，
不要跟他有瓜葛啊，
这俩都不是什么好的良配对，
如果只是还钱的话，
我特别愿意还，
因为我收入的工作都还蛮好的，
你一定要多观察啊，
多观察好不好，
好好好，
谢谢佩姐啊，
拜拜啊，
拜拜，
嗯，
我跟你们讲，
所有那种控制欲极强极变态的人，
他往往在外面表现出来都是极有礼貌，
极有修养，
极和善，
有很多东西他是可以学习的，
但有很多东西是他自己也无法改变的，
就是控制欲极强，
对某一些事情的话，
他就极在意。
你们认真去观察一下你身边周围有没有这样的人，
表面上所有人都觉得他是个好好先生，
所有人都觉得他又有修养又有礼貌，
只有你知道他控制欲有多强，
他有多变态。
记得点赞关注哦。